John Wick chapter 4 was the definitive
finale for the film series in more ways
in one but that doesn't mean there
aren't a few Windows still open that Jon
could leap through at any time John Wick
duels with Kane during the Epic
conclusion of John Wick chapter 4. and
while the Hitman conspires to trick and
ultimately defeat the film's real
villain the Marquis De gray Mall Wix it
comes to his wounds however after the
heartbreaking last moments in the movie
there's a post-credits scene between
Kane and Akira that alludes to a
possible spin-off but without the
franchise's main character or producer
Erica Lee seems to insist that audiences
should accept John Wick's Tombstone at
face value she's also not one to count
the Baba Yaga out during an interview
with collider Lee asked and answered her
own question saying I think that is that
character of John Wick dead yes are
there other versions or I don't know I
never say never it's a long life we're
developing other properties too and I
think that there's a lot of opportunity
for movies starring other characters or
other ways to World build movies that
are sort of handovers to different
characters indeed Wick might have
perished during his climactic battle at
Sunrise but there's another heavy hitter
involved in the fight box office within
days of the movie's release John Wick
chapter 4 had already made over 150
million dollars worldwide and the latest
installment continues to win over both
critics and audiences so given all the
spin-offs and development don't be
surprised if Reeves returns in the
future even if it's just as a cameo the
only way John Wick will ever have
even though John Wick is dead the
franchise is moving forward first up
there's the television miniseries the
Continental that will be followed by the
feature film titled ballerina
interestingly taking a look at
ballerina's credits on IMDb Keanu Reeves
is listed as a cast member because the
movie takes place between the third and
fourth films it's reasonable to believe
that John Wick could show up in the Anna
De armas-led project Erica Lee further
cemented the connection between the two
films when she said making ballerina has
actually been a really interesting
process because it's a lot of the stuff
that we take from the John Wick movies
but then it's slightly different it's
been fun to work on John Wick 4 and
ballerina kind of simultaneously and the
TV show the Continental it's a lot of
WIC but a lot of different versions of
it Erica Lee isn't the only John Wick
chapter 4 producer leaving the door open
for more Keanu Reeves in the franchise's
future producer basil ionic spoke to
Indy Weir about the film's final moments
and what it could mean for the
character's future stating it's an
ambiguous ending seeing John Wick's
grave certainly leaves an emotional
impact no one would want to diminish and
it's clear if Wix going to return to the
World Of Violence that has to be done in
the right way after all the movie shows
wait collapsing on a staircase before
cutting away to his grave in a cemetery
a lot could have happened between those
two scenes so there's room for Wake to
still be alive out there somewhere and
when it confirms that ambiguity was
intentional I don't think we've boxed
ourselves into any Corner whether he's
dead or alive at the end of this movie
with so many spin-offs in the works you
better believe that if those pulling the
strings think they can make Bank by
bringing Keanu Reeves back they'll do
everything they can to convince the star
to put on his Kevlar line suit jacket
one more time
[Music]